content on with stay in your vehicle
back in your car
drunk no
up there huh
a what Captain
of what the big don't reach in your
pocket get back in your car
116 show me 10-6 on Henry Lincoln Edward
497 at
MC I I will I'm not
[Music]
you've been drinking tonight
I just got a ride
you've been drinking tonight sir I'm the
captain Oh please forward what Police
Department Oklahoma City
what division
investigations
[Music]
what are you doing pulling in here my
mom and I stay here you've been drinking
[Music]
how much we had to drink tonight sir
huh
I'm not turning my camera off okay I'm
going to step out of the vehicle
you gotta be kidding me
yeah we're not gonna get a return on it
how much we drink tonight sir I was at a
poker game uh-huh
because you're swerving all over me when
you turn up you didn't use your signal
I'm sorry
how much you drink at your poker game
not much not much how much is not much I
don't know beer liquor not any beers
three or four three or four how long ago
was that
it's been going on in a while
how long ago did you drink your last
beer sir
what time is it now
it's zero 140.
midnight
you think you should drive it no but I
came from four vlogs
and your mom your mom lives here I live
here you live here yes
yes forward to the rear of your vehicle
okay you got your weapons or anything on
you I do not sir
just turn around we're gonna pat you
down go ahead
I promise you I'm not a problem okay
[Applause]
can I shut my door I'll shoot it for you
hang out there at the rear of your Chevy
[Applause]
what investigations are you with
yeah
you know Lieutenant Britain
yeah the weather it should be available
he works for dramatic Jermaine Johnson
yes
which means a good man too he is
hang on right there sir
that's your brothers
stem with feet together hands down by
your side for me and hands down by your
side please
look straight ahead and you see the tip
of my pincer I do and when she falls hit
my pin without moving your head okay
don't move your head sir
come over here it's a little bit more
level
you having those shoes in need
cause you for keeping your balance or
anything I don't think so you don't
think so okay I'm gonna demonstrate for
you first while I'm demonstrating I want
you to stand with your feet together
hands down by your side just like this
all right sir what's your name Matt
French Matt French
Mr French sounds just like that for me
okay when I tell you to begin when I
tell you to begin okay I'm just going to
demonstrate for you first I want you to
pick a foot of your choosing it doesn't
matter if it's your left or your right
foot I'm from here
and I want you to lift it approximately
six inches off the ground
and while you look at your toe I want
you to count by one thousands one
thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five so on and so forth until I
tell you to stop at any point in time
you lose your balance your foot touches
the ground just go ahead and pick your
foot back up and continue to count okay
do you understand these instructions of
explain times in French
you may begin
all right
now I cannot sir please I know you're
aware of our body cam policy you know I
cannot turn off this spot again but I'd
like to talk to you
I can't do that sir please
please
I like to talk to you
want are you going to do the test or not
before you please talk to me I'll talk
to you once you can turn it off and turn
it on I can turn it off once I'm done
with my investigations okay
oh
I'm asking you
I'm a Capstone I understand that sir and
I am a sergeant on this police officer
pulled the wall I don't show favoritism
to anyone regardless I don't care if
you're a gang banger or the president of
the United States sir I'm not asking for
that
if I was to treat you differently then I
was a treat like some South Side Loco or
some pedo how's that look on me okay I'm
not asking for that
because I wouldn't do that for any of
them
starting to scanner please
are you going to do the test or not sir
I will I will do whatever you ask okay
once we complete the test I'll turn off
my body again once I'm done with my
investigation
okay
you wanna you wanna try that again I
will
all right you may begin one two
three four
it's our place
please I'm asking you I can't do that
okay
so we're not going to do the test we
will
just keep stopping
okay let's try another test what is this
one of my partners who is it not sure
can't tell what the lights on
no it's
officer catch
you're familiar with the walk and turn
I am
going to demonstrate the walking turn
for you I want you to stand with your
left foot in front of your right foot
okay
heel to toe hands down by your side
can you do that for me sir
you want left foot in front of the right
yes sir hands down by your side
okay attempt to hold that position while
I demonstrate for you you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps counting out
loud one two three four and we'll say
that's nine on your ninth step without
lifting your lead foot you're gonna
pivot like so
and then you're gonna take nine Heel To
Toe steps counting each step out loud
back the way you came until you get to
nine do you understand these
instructions I've explained to you Mr
French I believe so all right anytime
you're ready you may begin
corn
to three
[Applause]
one
two three
four five six seven eight nine all right
go ahead and turn around for me put your
answer on your back oh you got arrested
myself yes I am
can I talk to you
go ahead and put your handsprank your
back Sir
yeah we'll turn the camera off now thank
you
I'd like